they're live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout I'm super
excited to be with you guys again this
week today I have a really special guest
Eric Harbison who is from Aweber and
he's in charge of all of their marketing
and he's coming on board to share with
us some of his ideas on how to grow your
business through email marketing so Eric
welcome aboard
I've been great to be here looking
forward to it love it we've got a lot of
great questions if those are you
watching if you have a question for me
or Eric you can leave it there on the
side of that right hand side and we'll
do our best to go to an answer for you
Eric though before we kind of dive in on
the questions is there some high level
advice you can give to entrepreneur
trying to grow their list and build a
business through email yeah so a lot of
conversations I have with with
entrepreneurs around email is that
there's there's three main or three
basic phases I'd like to see them
towards and that's when it comes to
getting started or comes to evolving
what they have there's three phases I
call them the the build grow phase then
there's the engagement phase and then
there's what I like to call the eyes
phase and what that means is there's the
analyze optimize and monetize so if you
follow those three phases when it comes
to building your list you know typically
what falls underneath that you know the
specific strategies and tactics to to
make the most of it so that's that's
typically the advice I'll give I love it
you know I've been using email for I
don't know 10 to 15 years something in
there I've been in a web or customer I
think from the start and it's still my
number one way to promote something that
I have coming up as much as I love
YouTube and social media and my website
when something needs to have what I need
to drive attention to something email is
still my number one option and so I'm
super excited to answer questions you
guys and talk about email so let's get
into it first question comes from Robert
he wrote a kind of a long question but
I've written my first advertisement
which has been published which will be
published in two weeks and delivered to
my private houses and the 30-mile radius
from his business I have a new email
account and I dedicate to the new
business I'm expecting the
advertisements you get me some emails
with which your help and advice I might
cultivate into an email list so I'm
starting from
zero how do we become an email hero
please
easy Robert it sounds like you've got a
very very focused initiative and
objective and if it's a matter of
getting started with those names I would
probably start with creating content
that's very specific to those folks or
those that you're trying to target
within that radius a way to grow your
list is to provide educational content
relevant to what you stand for or what
your business represents so if it's
things to do in the area or if it's just
you know quick tips on historical things
about that area it sounds like it may be
a real estate angle real estate company
but if you if you create that content to
be put into your emails just by the fact
that you're serving that relevant
information to here trying to target
even if it's only five people that will
help to grow that list just by a sheer
nature that you're providing relevant
information I love it what's interesting
about this is he's using kind of
traditional ways of advertising most
people think of building email is from a
website not from doing a direct mail
campaign I would make sure that on your
direct mail piece or your advertisement
piece there's some incentive to want to
sign up for the newsletter you're giving
away some kind of free bonus I'm sure
we'll talk about this later on again the
strategies but give them a reason to
want to sign up and then like Eric
talked about giving them value in the
newsletter so if you're creating the
autoresponder sequence or you're
creating specialized broadcaster people
you want to build that relationship with
them first establish yourself as an
expert first and then once they know you
like you trust you they're much more
likely to want to do business with you
and using that direct mail piece in that
traditional advertising you have a lot
of real estate there to explain the
value and to you know communicate what
someone will get by going to a specific
URL to sign up or even in some cases you
can set up text to join mailing lists
where you can just you know people still
use text and you know connecting that
offline to online environment it's a
very valuable way to get folks on your
list and part of growing your audience I
did not know you could do text to join
there you go I've learned something
in the first five minutes of this
session already I love it cool so the
next question comes is from J rise is a
loyal viewer do you feel that every
business benefits of email marketing or
are there certain examples where the
model wouldn't fit huh I mean my
personal opinion on that is email can be
used I mean you think about a business a
business is around to connect with
customers and build relationships so
email is the best vehicle to do that so
I think any business can really use
email in terms of wanting to provide a
product or service you know to answer
the question about you know what
business or what model wouldn't fit you
know all I can really think of as
anybody who's you know first objective
is to deceive or be deceptive in trying
to build a list or to you know build
lists for the purposes of selling names
something that is not really you know
meant to build a fruitful relationship
in terms from a from a philosophical
what sort of business or business model
would not be a fit for email I look at
you know anyone who's not prepared to
invest time and effort towards you know
nurturing and building a very very you
know robust audience because you know
our email any email database that you
have including our own you know has a
shelf life and if you're not building it
for purposes of growing it and engaging
with it then you know that's that's a
business that probably should not be
doing evil yeah I love it you know my
default answer was every business except
people who aren't using email you know
if you're selling to the Amish or
Mennonite people or something maybe
maybe that's not a fit but otherwise I
mean anybody everybody uses email and so
there's an opportunity to build a list
and and I totally agree with that Eric
is talking about making sure you're
coming in from it in the right spot from
the right core values if you want to
have success you want to think about
it's a long term relationship with your
clients cool helper desk what content do
you find best works for your email
marketing should you emails be targeting
your new prospects or your loyal
customers
perhaps separate lists for both groups I
think the answer is in the question
there because you know the answer is
definitely segment
content - if you're able to identify you
know non customers or soon-to-be
customers and your customers that
absolutely provide content that's
relevant to each you know one way to
think about it is that if you have
established that list of I've got a you
know I've got a list of names that are
you know people that aren't customers
yet well the content you want to be
focusing for them is most likely
education about your industry or your
service line forget about selling them
let's let's focus on getting them smart
about what it is that that you do what
your industry provides and then when you
come to your customers you know focus on
providing them education around how to
use your product or service or get the
most out of your product or service
because again they've invested they're a
customer so you want to go to nurture
mode with that list as well so yes on
segmenting but again think of education
on industry for potentials and education
around your product or service for
customers I love it and I think this is
where autoresponders can be really
powerful yeah for those of you for those
of you who don't know what our
responders are is basically when
somebody signs up for your list on a set
schedule and frequency they get certain
emails that you have pre crafted and so
you write the email once and then you
know seven days later from joining the
list they get that email and then
another seven days later whatever
interval you want they get more emails
and so I think the autoresponders are an
amazing way to educate the new people to
your list as well as build authority and
build trust and be seen as a friend
so as example if you join my email list
I have 75,000 people on my list or so
you know you'll get it you'll get a
welcome email from me and then it's six
days later you'll get a list of my
favorite YouTube videos and then a week
later you'll get a list of my top ten
books for entrepreneurs and a weekly -
you get another email with my favorite
quotes for entrepreneurs just all sorts
of kind of value-add stuff that helps me
tell the story and build a relationship
and I think that really helps educate
the new people to your list and then
your broadcasts or the kind of one-off
emails that you can send like when I was
promoting this event I sent it to my
email list yesterday morning as a
broadcast
right I don't want it to be an
autoresponder because it's happening in
a specific time so this is a broadcast
and I'm sending out and that goes to
everybody goes to my prospects that goes
to my clients Eric is there an easy way
to once somebody has purchased from you
to move them to a separate list if I'm
using a weber
yes and there's a way to tag the
customers based on what you know about
them to then set up for a separate you
know series you know focused primarily
on that educational information so you
know we're able to you're not just doing
once you know somebody is in but also
based on where they're signing up from
you know there's ways to segment based
off of that so that's very powerful
because you may be in an event where
it's nothing but prospects and just by
capturing names of that event you're
able to start that series from from
immediately when they provide you that
information or sign up to the list
provide them information that's focused
on prospects because you knew they came
from an area where there was nothing but
opportunity so definitely as possible
that's interesting so so if I go to a
conference and you know I'm collecting a
bunch of names and people are you know I
want to send into a page they get more
information and on there is an email
list I can then funnel them to a
separate list where they're getting
information with autoresponders that
talked about that conference okay here
are 10 things I learned from the
conference that might be beneficial to
you correct and what you is a business
they're what you believe was the best
you know outcomes from that conference
or learnings from that conference you
know so all that again that really
forces you to think about when it comes
to building your list and growing your
lists you know sometimes those live
events could be very very popular but
also take the same thought process apply
to your blog or your Facebook page or
other areas where you're going to be
growing your lists because the context
of where all the the the names are
coming in you know it's important it's
important because you know if it's
coming from an area where there may be
both prospects and customers well then
you can give the choice of having
somebody self select are you a customer
yes or no and that too allows you to
trigger or segment off into you know
prospect versus
temir follow-up series cool so so if I'm
building a list in my Facebook page I
could then have as my first email some
of my top 10 Facebook posts of all time
yeah welcome them from Facebook yeah
it's I mean I think that does a lot to
really build the relationship and make
it seem like you care and it's because
you actually do care hopefully clients
cool
Sherri's writing in I'm making groups in
my email contact so when I want to email
one group to target everything it's in
order to start would it be benefit to
send out manually sounds like she's just
doing things through our email program
instead of using any SP right yep yep so
I think you know what when it comes to
signs that tells you that it's time to
potentially invest excuse me an email
service provider it's when you are doing
things manually like like described here
so if your bc and seeing bc seen your
contacts you know from an Outlook or
from a gmail environment you know
investing in an ESP you know whether
it's just trying something for free for
30-days may be worth doing to identify
the time it's going to save you but then
also the power and the you know the
ability to send more than just one it
may take you what takes you five hours
now may take you one hour and then you
can do more of that within the five
hours you may a lot to focus in on email
yeah I love it you know a few thoughts
that I have here is one if you just send
an email through a BCC it's super
unperson alized right people are not
really gonna read it where if you if you
can customize and put their name in then
people are much more likely to read and
feel like it's it's for them to you have
limits and this is what I struggled with
when I first started and what I switch
to getting an email service provider you
can only send so many emails out before
you start getting limited from your
email provider you could do mail merges
I used to do mail merges through my
Outlook but then I'm with Rogers
Internet and I can only send X amount
per hour then they sort of copy me and
then
the other thing that I really find
helpful is Aweber has this tool that
helps you determine whether an email
will go to spam or not yep which I find
super helpful
so whatever message that you want to
send you plug in there first and it will
say listen this has a high spam score
because you use these three words and if
you take out those words or replace them
with something else that may seem super
trivial and easy to you but that might
increase the chance of your email
getting into those people's email
inboxes by an insane percentage and so
once I saw that feature today we're like
I got a good side and then just managing
just you know the ability to unsubscribe
right you you can't just spam people
there has to wait for them to
unsubscribe from your list they don't
want to hear from you anymore so there's
so many reasons to move to an email
service provider and it doesn't have to
cost a lot right I mean what does Aweber
start I mean this is a free trial but
then at the base what are we looking at
for eweber $19 up to 500 subscribers and
if you think about it you know if
there's you know the if you're serious
about growing your business and you have
you know not everyone's selling
something first
not everyone is selling something you
know terms of product or a widget but if
you think about the value that can come
from just a $19 investment it's it's
really conversations we find ourselves
just in knowing the space and talk not
Renault's is your IP and your knowledge
is something that is worth it can be
monetized so for $19 as a starting point
that's very easy for businesses to get
that back over time and it shouldn't
take you know maybe you give yourself a
three to six month window to create some
IP whether it's a PDF or something that
is that is a value to your audience that
for $19 $29 it's something you can sell
and that is easily gonna offset the cost
of the ESP yeah I think honestly as soon
as your list gets to like 25 people
you're emailing more than 25 people at a
time I'd be looking at getting some
software because it's just not worth the
headache and hassle correct okay cool
next Kaba I hope I pronounced that
properly there are some communities
where technology is not fully
embraced how can we use email marketing
effectively to them yes so when I when I
figure this question it sounds like you
know there's there may be certain areas
or societies that don't have access to
the technology therefore email may not
be something that is seen as something
to connect and engage with certain
audiences you know if I if I if I
understand it correctly if that's the
case but there is some penetration of
technology where you you can get e-mails
back and forth you know I see that as a
way to use email as a catalyst to
increase awareness so you know yes it's
all about building a relationship and an
audience but you know I see it as a way
to you know connect with those that do
have connectivity to increase awareness
and messaging to those that do not
whether that's an incentive program that
comes for the email that's being
connected but just use it as a catalyst
to connect with those that do not have a
technology yeah I think email is I mean
it's fairly low-tech you don't have to
have an insane set up to be able have an
email address but back to one of the
questions we answered at the top is it
for everybody
again if you're selling to the Mennonite
or Amish and they don't have emails then
maybe this marketing strategy isn't the
best for you but if your audience has an
email address then you should definitely
be looking at email marketing yeah
davon hey Evan and Eric I'm going to
start grad school for entrepreneurship
my career plan is to work a regular job
until I'm done and then break out what
should I be doing email wise until then
yeah I mean I love the the passion and
there's actually a plan of attack that
is coming from from from daven or Devon
you know for me it goes back to the what
I mentioned at the top around those
phases if you have any idea about what
you're passionate about you're kind of
in that bill growth phase if you plan
eventually to make this a full-time
pursuit then I would imagine you have
some idea about what you want how you
want to position yourself so I would
start by you know creating content
that's relevant to the audience that you
want to grow and just by nature of
having that you know ten tips on
whatever and let's
assume that Damon is gonna be a you know
he's a photographer and he wants to be
an expert in photography well you know
start by building your your ten tips on
what what type of equipment to buy or
you know writing blog posts that are
aligned with that topic and then use
that as a way to build a list and the
good news is that you'd vest hours to
create that post it on your social
footprint and LinkedIn in other groups
that are relevant to that content and
and people will start finding that
information and your list will start to
grow as you're going to school so that
by the time you're ready to make the
move you can assess what you've grown in
terms of an audience and then figure out
how to monetize it from that from from
there yeah I think one of the biggest
problems or regrets that I find a lot of
entrepreneurs have is they wish they had
started sooner yeah in building their
list yeah and I love this question
because you haven't even started and he
wants to build a list right away and
it's great that's that's the way to
really be thinking I mean I love Eric's
advice I'd be thinking what platform is
best for you to search in your knowledge
whether that's videos on YouTube whether
you know if you're great on camera do
that if you're great at writing start a
blog find the platform that best speaks
to what your talents are great at and
then immediately start building your
list through that at the end of your
YouTube video you have a link to sign up
for your news there at the end of every
blog post or guest blog post you're
doing you have a link to sign up for
your newsletter and and then start
adding value right what can you add in
the autoresponder to start adding value
and start helping people
what kind of broadcast can you put into
again start helping your readers now get
more get more help with the challenges
they're facing even if you don't
necessarily have a product or service to
sell yet just by building up that
awareness and by adding value to
people's lives when you are ready to
come up with a product or service to
sell you have an audience that has been
following you along and they're much
more likely to join you wherever you go
and one other quick point on that is
I'll go back to John who who was on
earlier a couple months ago about
partnerships yeah if you have something
you're passionate about
you know it's it's even also effective
to go reach out to folks that may you
know have that blog or have that site
where you can partner with them to be
seen as a thought leader before you even
get your business off the ground so you
already when you're ready to make the
move you've got a kind of one-to-many
approach figure it out where you've made
those partnerships and have those
conversations with folks in that
specific space I love it
Phares wrote in hello Evan and Eric how
do I promote my business with
newsletters how should I come up with
daily or weekly email ideas for my
clients daily weekly notes for my
clients so this is assuming that there's
yeah it all goes back to the content it
all goes back to you know what is the
business what problem are you solving
with your business or your service in
terms of like weekly and monthly the
first question I would ask is do you
does your audience even want daily
messages do they want weekly messages so
let's assume that they do you know
courses are a great a great way to you
know satisfy somebody who wants that
information on a daily basis so whatever
your product or your service is is how
do you chunk that out to like here are
six tips and then there's one tip per
day and I would most likely test that
over the course of a couple of weeks to
see what kind of response you get
because some people may think they want
daily and then realize that you know
every other day every third day is
probably better for them so tips is
great for weekly sorry for daily for
weekly it all goes back to the tip what
you're saying I've been about value so
what is it about your space whether it's
you know right now this time of year or
the future of and kind of trends for
next year are important in every pretty
much every landscape for every business
so you know you know Tommy toe right now
you know
you know holiday is important of course
but you know give more kind of prophetic
statements on where you see your
specific product or service going and
that could serve as a nice weekly check
point and quite frankly even monthly as
well I love it yeah and you can
definitely over email your client base I
think back to you know Groupon when a
Groupon came out
everybody was excited though Groupon and
then now you get a Groupon e-mail and
like do you even read it anymore it's
just been like just too much just too
many emails more important than the
quantity that was going to be the
quality right to Eric's point it's got
to add value people will read it if it's
adding meaningful value to their lives
if I was doing a daily thing I would
probably have something super short and
something kind of inspirational
motivational kind of start your day with
this quote or tip right now I post to my
audience twice a week I'll usually do a
regular broadcast newsletter that goes
out every Wednesday morning I tested
that Wednesday morning at 5 a.m. seems
to have the highest open rates on my
email list so that's when I post my
newsletter and then I do my ongoing
series the autoresponders every week
from when they signed up so if somebody
signs up but Sunday at 3 a.m. they're
gonna keep getting emails at Sunday at 3
a.m. because that's when they're likely
to be online to that point Eric can you
talk about testing and and how you
handle it because it's it's such a
powerful feature of the Aweber
platform to really help you get the most
out of each user that you send out yes
but split testing is usually the topic
that you know entrepreneurs and
businesses are trying to grapple and and
maybe try to perfect but you know it's
something that's always gonna be ongoing
and it's always gonna be something on a
test so within Aweber split testing
subject lines and content and your email
is always something that can be done
it's just a matter of you know making
sure you know what you want to
accomplish you talked about what I what
sounds like you know the best time of
day or best day a week to send and you
know whenever I'm asked that question my
answer is always yes for the point you
just made is that somebody may be
engaging with their emails on Sunday
night at which point they want to get
that email or they're most receptive to
that email on Sunday night if you're
sending a broadcast where it's going to
be kind of that one message to everybody
on your on your list
you know that's something that's worth
testing because you know with with over
a half of all emails being open up on
mobile devices you have to consider that
in terms of when and where someone's
going to be consuming your email message
and you know that's where I like to say
you know there's some businesses where
two o'clock on a Tuesday may be better
than you know someone who's you know
trying to target a mobile centric
audience where you know in the morning
commute might be worth it if it's
someone in a in a you know a community
city so you really have to figure out
you know who who's your audience and
what other consumption habits you know
to determine when and how you would best
you know test that day at time of day or
day a week cool yeah and for those of
you know the audience watching now who
may not be super familiar with the
mechanics of split testing basically
what it allows you to do is you can have
multiple emails go out to segments of
your list so if you have a thousand
people on your list you could have you
know four different versions go out and
a weber automatically pick a random 250
people to get version a 250 get version
B and so on and then it'll show you the
open rates for each version that'll show
you how many people clicked on to your
website or did whatever call-to-action
you ask them today and so it allows you
to kind of figure out what time of day
works better what subject line works
very well call-to-action works better
and that can help you kind of define and
improve your campaigns ongoing and it's
great that that's kind of built in and
all the analytics and that that's where
the value really comes in using an email
service provider to help you kind of
launch your campaigns and have success
with it and so I think it's last point
of that is make sure you're testing one
thing at a time right it's the rule in
marketing like test your subject lines
right and just figure that out and then
test your time of day and day of week
right because you never know what's
gonna work until you can isolate just
that one variable I think anybody in
marketing I guess as you grew up to like
the corporate world do you understand
that but a lot of entrepreneurs when
they're split testing have too many
variables and then it doesn't help
make kind of good decisions right
pastor D I'm launching a new product and
I'm targeting new prospects how do I
start my list from scratch
I'll go back to the framework of of
those phases you know how do you start
from scratch if there is a new product
again whether it's a widget or an online
project or online product or something
like that it's if you're starting from
scratch I think that's that's an
advantageous position to be in because
you can kind of see what's being said
about this product and then again it's
all about creating the content that's
going to want somebody
I'll give somebody a need to give you
their email address to get that valuable
content that you've produced and I know
it sounds like kind of a not so much a
catch-all but but it you know it works
but if you're unable to provide a piece
of content in order to kind of get
started with growing your list then you
you you find a much bigger battle of
trying to get people interested in why
would they want to give you their their
email in the first place
so you know using that that piece of
content and again when I say piece of
content it could be a two page PDF it
could be a coupon if you have a
brick-and-mortar store if you have some
sort of for sale item anything that
really show that you're providing value
in you know kind of the give to get
models so it's you know in receiving the
email your audience is actually
receiving something of value specific to
your product in order to obtain that
email and then start building that
relationship yeah I love it and I think
to kind of speed that up too back to the
point Erica's talking about John was
talking about forming partnerships yeah
I would look at who already has your
target audience whatever product this is
that you're gonna be creating who
already owns that target audience and
how can you get in front of that target
audience so you know as an example
anybody wanting to sell entrepreneurs
it'd be great to be on my youtube
channel because I have an audience and
can help promote and give some exposure
you know you should be that person so
reach out to people with popular YouTube
channels and popular blogs and are big
on Instagram and Twitter and find out
how you might be able to contribute to
their success create a PDF create a
whitepaper be a guests on their show and
have a call to action to visit your
website and sign up for your newsletter
with the free bonus or something that
they can download and be a part of I
think you can you can try to do the
usual kind of slow growth with with SEO
and building content out but the way to
ramp it up and get there faster is to
again find people who already have your
target audience and figure out a way
that you might be able to work together
to provide value to their audience cool
my Tefo is writing in I've managed to
build a significant database from the
events that I host and attend which
system is best to use that will enable
me to communicate I see that you're
using Aweber would you recommend it and
which other ones are available that
don't cost an arm and a leg well you
know my answer you know my answer to I
mean I've been using Aweber for as I
said over 10 years I've loved it along
the way this and we started a
relationship together I guess the number
of months ago but I've been a client of
Aweber
since I started building my list and the
thing that impressed me most ash with
Aweber was the service because a lot of
the technical features may not be that
different between the providers I could
be wrong I haven't I haven't dug deep
into the competitors to see how they're
different but the service level was
something I super appreciated where you
could call up you can actually have a
phone call with somebody who will help
walk you through the problems and some
of the problems are little minor things
but if you're not an expert and you know
a techie it may be hard for you to
figure out and they always are nice and
friendly and helpful and just kind of
the opposite of most call centers that
at least I've had an experience with and
for you know for those you've watched
every kind of Aweber chat that we've had
on YouTube channel everybody's just a
nice person who comes on and there's
just something good about working with
nice people who want to see you succeed
and so I would you know I I need an a
wipe or shirt or something I would be I
would recommend
all the others and it doesn't have to
cost you now I'm gonna leg to right as
we talk about the free trial is 30 days
you have 19 dollars a month for up to
500 people on your list and then it
costs more as you grow your list right
so as you grow hopefully making money
from it makes sense to invest a little
bit more into the software so I think
it's been designed so that it's it's a
super low entry point from anybody to
get into and start having success with
yeah just one quick point on the
customer support angle is that you're
right in the fact that you know getting
people over the hump of getting used to
a technology and kind of Windows and and
buttons and things like that you know
that those are definitely conversations
we have but for those that kind of know
how to get past that in they're familiar
with the interface from from whether
either another ESP or something else you
know our customer support team and you
you may have experienced this is that
it's support not just from the platform
standpoint but support from your
business standpoint so if you're not
sure when to test something or you have
questions about your strategy or how to
best use what you've built our team is
ready to answer those questions with you
too and you know you'll get strategic
support as much as you will technical
support and that's the best thing about
our team is that they're so skilled and
they're experts across not just the
product but also the email industry that
you know there's a lot of great
conversations that I overhear down there
about helping people strategize with you
know when to launch that test or you
know images or even design of an email
so I think that's another value that
you'll get if you're looking to test an
ESD yeah I mean yeah for me it feels
like they actually care that you're not
just reading off some script but that
they actually care about my business and
what I'm doing and you know I don't need
to name-drop Eric's name to get good
service it's just kind of built into the
company so cool obviously we're both
biased so you know that's our answer but
you asked so there you go
psyched to go why are companies like
buzzfeed.com
not taking full advantage of an email
list and instead relying on social media
if they wanted to they can convert all
their social media followers to an email
list yeah that's that's an interesting
question because you look at
BuzzFeed and what they represent and
they most likely you know why they don't
do it I don't know that we can answer
that other than as soon that their
strategy is really to embrace kind of a
social landscape and they may not want
to convert all that all that social the
audience onto an email list although
they may have portions of it or they may
do some of it but I agree in that you
know straight that psyched to go saw
that as like seems like a missed
opportunity not knowing what BuzzFeed is
doing I you know there is opportunity to
do that and if you just take that
observation and apply to your business
there definitely should be you know
thought around how do you use social to
build your audience in your email and
how to use your email audience that you
have to increase the engagement in your
social platforms so specific to BuzzFeed
could be a strategic decision but how
that relates to your business or what
you're trying to accomplish as an
entrepreneur you should definitely see
the two as you know two areas that can
complement each other I mean I think
Eric's answer echoes a lot of what I'm
feeling - I think there's any company
you can look at look at Microsoft or
Google or Toyota and you can come up
with a million ideas like why are they
doing this and maybe it's a hole in
their plan like maybe they have thought
it through or maybe they haven't but
again without being on the inside it's
hard to really know I think social is a
lot sexier I think it's a lot more you
know mainstream and on the tip of
everybody's tongue and from somebody you
know me who is hardcore on social and
all in on YouTube and spend a ton of
time a disproportion amount of time on
YouTube I need my social networks I
still find insane value in email and
again if I had to get something out and
drive people to join a car like this or
buy a product my email this is the first
place that I would go and so I don't see
them like Eric talked about as being
mutually exclusive like you have to do
social or you have to do email they
support each other right email can help
your social campaigns social campaigns
can help your email list but if you want
to get in front of somebody immediately
email is still the number one place in
my book because if I make a youtube
video it's not guaranteed
go to all the my hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers right alright if I
put out a tweet it's not guaranteed to
hit everybody same thing with Facebook
anywhere else where email it's not going
to t that they're going to open it but
it's hitting their inbox and people
still check their inbox every day where
they may not check every single feed on
YouTube every day and every single
Twitter account every day and so I still
think there's insane value even though
it may not be as sexy of social it's an
insane value to help your business grow
yep great all right um
Rishi Cup TV hey Evan and Eric how might
we how might we want to consider
differentiating the value would provide
through email marketing from our other
social media marketing so that it stands
out in a good way thank you yes so this
this kind of the answer you just gave
kind of touches on that a little bit and
one thing I can use or one thing I can
say to kind of support that or support
what you're saying is you know when
everyone opened theirs built their
social media platforms it was always you
know think about it like a you know a
cocktail party I think about a party or
hosting or you need to make sure
everyone is engaged through using you
know showing videos and images and
things like that but if you think of
social media as your you know kind of
you hosting the party think of email
marketing is your coffee date where it's
one-to-one and it's all about you and
the person you're sitting across the
table from you know versus the other end
of your email so if you think of it that
way
what sort of conversations would you
have in social that you wouldn't have on
that one-on-one coffee date so obviously
the answer here is that there's more
personalization there's more you know
direct listening and the ability to set
expectations it says I'm gonna you know
let's do this again next Tuesday and
actually you know commit to doing that
with that individual so the expectation
setting that you can do an email allows
you to be more successful in you know if
you're a business it's sign up for my
weekly newsletter every Tuesday I'm
gonna give you five pieces of advice to
grow your business I'm going to check my
email every Tuesday so you're able to
set that expectation in email regardless
of the noise and the other emails to
come in in
your inbox Yorick's you're looking for
that email or if you see that email you
there's a connection then you have a
greater likelihood of opening that up
yeah I love it I like that analogy that
you made that's pretty cool
I mean I'd also remembered that email is
a is a written first platform yeah so
what you would put in a newsletter
versus what you create in a YouTube
video the strategy might be a little bit
different but it's true like to Eric's
point I can't get in a YouTube video and
say hey Rishi Captiva it's great to have
you back you know I mean we can mention
you live broadcast but otherwise I'm
talking to everybody we're in a
newsletter you can really customize it
and back to what we're talking about
before I can customize it further too if
I know that came from an event or if I
know that they're a customer of mine
versus a prospect or any other
information I have about them that I've
tagged I can make that newsletter really
fit what they want where with a social
post yes you could have I guess a
YouTube channel for customers versus
prospects doesn't really happen that
much it's very much more than what kind
of one-to-many approach with most of
social yeah
Tamara writes in is there a way to get
email addresses with YouTube what's the
best way to obtain email addresses what
is the best kind of content to include
in a newsletter how often should emails
be sent out lots of questions I feel
like we would address the number them
already but how about through YouTube
the you see strategies work in the email
addresses through YouTube yeah so you
know and you administer layer where at
the end of a video your if you're
engaged in somebody or somewhere in the
middle of a video if it's you know more
than five or ten minutes long is
encourage people to engage or go off to
a link there are some video platforms
that allow you to embed email capture
forms inside of the video so when the
video is done enter your email here and
you can engage and grow and capture
names from the video itself so so there
are ways to basically you know link off
and get people to go to a page to maybe
get more information before giving you
an email address or you can just simply
capture that email information
right from the video itself can you do
that within YouTube embed form I'm not
sure if YouTube is form ready but like
Wistia and Vimeo have options where you
can embed certain in certain variations
like that so that's cool that would be
amazing so I gotta look into that how I
do it I get a lot of people for my
newsletter from YouTube we have an end
card so when the video is done there's
an end card it usually goes and most
people just promote hey watch my next
video my previous video or maybe
subscribe to the channel where I want to
get people on my news that's priority
and so the the free bonus that I give
people when they sign up for my
newsletter for my website I have a
little picture of promoting that and on
every end card and then use an
annotation link to send people to a
landing page where they can sign up for
the newsletter actually not to be super
helpful and again you get a much greater
increase if you promise somebody
something download my free pdf and
Senate from Anna's live and just sign up
for my newsletter
correct correct and I think the you know
Tamara's question is coming from the
right point which is you know never
wanting to kind of let the video just
end and end the engagement with just
that you always want to give your your
audience whether it's prospects or
customers an opportunity to learn more
to get more you know to be aware of more
things that are coming out of your
product or your service so you know the
intent there tamara is great it's always
want to give your audience you know the
option and never have that you know that
piece of content and you know abruptly
with like thanks for watching and then
that's it you know so you know
connecting and collecting email
addresses is definitely a way to do that
you know yeah and then I mean taking
that down a little bit further you could
send them and I don't do this I should
you can send it to a page that then tags
into a YouTube list so you know they
came from YouTube your welcome email you
say hey so glad you came here from my
youtube videos here are my five favorite
from my channel right you can super
customize your that list to be just from
your YouTube audience and then I'm
assuming that will help increase the
engagement and the connection to you as
well I need any
back to the text and join comment I made
earlier is think of those that are
consuming your video if that's happening
a lot via mobile or on-the-go just
having kind of an overlay that speaks to
text this to join my list or to get this
download or something like that is
another way to do it so that you're
considerate of somebody having to go do
something differently and kind of
disembark from the engagement is just
use the text to join that's that your
really interesting because so much of
the youtube consumption is mobile yeah
that for them to then click I don't
think even you can click on an
annotation has to be a card for them to
click on the card and then go to a
website and then fill in their name and
email and all that that's a lot of steps
DRS and somebody on the phone to do they
can just text a joint hmm yeah I'm we
thinking Eric I like it change is coming
to my youtube channel people I love it I
love it okay you Jobs is writing insane
that their audience consists of business
professionals and businesses and making
a connection between them and so I was
wondering about how to create campaigns
to attract both audiences the
professionals and the businesses yeah so
this just pulling some pieces from from
earlier comments we made but you've jobs
I would probably have a you know you
probably know someone who's in that
professional segment and knows someone
who's in that you know business wanting
to hire someone segments if you just ask
them for like one of the five things you
look for in your respective camps well
there's your first PDF again PDF only
has to be you know two three pages even
two pages it's what it's the value that
you're providing for that which is going
to help you engage those that want to
get that information so if it's a
professional
who wants to work online I'm assuming
this may be like a freelance opportunity
or something like that well then it's
you know here are the five signs that
you're ready to to be a freelancer well
if I'm a freelancer or thinking about
being a freelancer I want to download
that PDF and then you have a list of you
know folks that are in that mindset and
that could or should help you grow that
audience and then on the other side from
the from a business stand
it's the five signs that you're ready to
outsource or the 5 signs you're ready to
freelance and you already have that
information from the businesses that
you've interviewed so now you can take
that information package it up and have
that at the ready and you know at the
ready means you need to distribute it
with those businesses and professionals
that you currently work with we talked
about partnerships you know that's
another angle to help distribute that
but then also within you jobs probably
has its own social presence already and
you can announce and distribute this
information through those networks as
well I love it and I think because you
have to Stoli separate audiences that
you need to two different lists correct
content interesting for one for the
professionals is not what the businesses
care about what is prospects and
customers there may be content that
overlaps yeah right that you can send to
everybody but in this case I feel like
you just need two totally different
lists two totally different opt-ins two
totally different bonus guides two
totally autoresponders and like if it's
weekly campaigns and monthly campaigns
they each need to be different because
if you combine them it's not as relevant
anymore
hey Evan and Eric should you mention the
name of the recipient in the email
example dear Mike or should you avoid it
huh I was actually at a roundtable
discussion last week with a with a group
of b2b b2c marketers and this question
came up and it's interesting to see
everyone's take on it because there's
the creepy factor of being too
personalized but then there's the the
option of well isn't personalization
better and should that help
so for affairs in terms of this this
answer is you know it's always worth
testing you know going back to what we
mentioned earlier but one thing I will
say is that if you're collecting names
and if you're building an audience ask
yourself if you even need to capture a
first in the last name don't capture
unless you plan to use it in some way
and typically if you're going to ask for
it it's it's using personalization
within subject line and with a header
we've seen increased click-through rates
in subject lines where we did feature
personalization so again that's why I
feel like it's worth every business to
test that out but again going back to
thinking of you know if your business
truly operates on its it's
personalization may be nice but is it is
it a nice to have or need to have think
about how many more leads you'd be able
to capture if all you focused on is just
getting their business email address and
then down the line you can maybe ask for
you know name information if you plan to
use it but you know that that's
something also we're testing is do you
really need to capture all that
information if really what you're
providing is so valuable the
personalization may be nice but it may
not be necessary interesting yeah I mean
I think I think the creepy factor is
kind of gone with email people are how
many newsletters you sign up when people
are using your name I don't know I feel
like it's not that big a deal anymore
but but test I mean I found in all my
test that two things one I always start
an email now with I don't use dear I
think I say hi or hey like even
something like that you test right I
test it hi versus hey vs. dear all can
make a difference on your click-through
rate right that's why you take pepper to
test things out but more than that I put
it in the subject to where it'll say
like for Evan - and then the subject of
my email for Eric - right I found that
that dramatically increases the open
rates and I've never had anybody write
to me saying this is creepy don't use my
name you know if they sign up for this
right they know me from somewhere wanted
my newsletter so it's not like why are
you emailing me how do you know my name
they filled out the form and have never
had that issue come up but again I mean
like Eric said test test test test see
what works for you I think you'll find
that it dramatically increases your your
open rates and your conversion rates if
you use their name and a cool thing
about a weber - is the first name fix
you can insert I think it's by default
now it didn't used to be but it's a it's
a first name fixed it'll capitalize the
name the first letter of the name so
even if they filled out the form if I
put in a bin with a small e it'll make
it capitalized so it looks a little more
professional and authentic cool Jennifer
price what do you feel is more important
the subject line or the content great
question and I think just when you think
about the subject line is what gets you
to the content so I would say you know
just at a high level
probably the subject line is more
important when you when you just isolate
that email in terms of its success but
what I will say is that you know there
could be an answer that says the content
is more valuable in terms of how you
capture that information or how you
captured somebody's name because if the
expectation is set that's so clear I
could use a subject line that says hey
and that's it but if I if my expectation
is if the expectations are so clear as
the brand product and service I'm gonna
open up that email no matter what and
one example is there's a there's an
entrepreneur that I follow and I sign up
for his his email list and he did such a
great job of setting expectations of
what's going to be sent and when it's
gonna be sent and what's going to be in
the newsletter that and he may have been
testing himself but one subject line he
had sent references mother of all things
but you know guess what okay got my
attention but because it came from him I
knew exactly was going to be in that
email and I knew exactly what the
content was going to be so subject line
was kind of whatever all I did was get
my attention but even if the subject
line was not that I know exactly the
content that was going to be in that
newsletter so for me the content Trump
the subject line that's it you're saying
are there people uh and then be a good
share like whose newsletters do you love
or look up to as best practices that
people watching might be able to go sign
up for their letters newsletters as well
and get a sense of what they're doing
yeah sure so it's funny because you know
- maybe even a year and a half two years
ago newsletters you know couldn't sign
up for enough of them now I find myself
getting into podcast a lot more - which
is again another great Avenue and you
know something entrepreneurs a lot of
entrepreneurs are looking into but
you know what I tend the newsletters I
tend to sign up for are those that are
that that are trying to be best in class
in their individual spaces so buffer app
is always a good one
leadpages is another good one in terms
of like other entrepreneurs
Nathan latke from heyo is one jeez John
James from duct-tape marketing is
another one that's a great newsletter
you know HubSpot you know I could
recognize that they do a heck of a job
with their content so there's no their
newsletters are always very informative
so those are just the some and I could
always share some others cool I didn't
know buffer I've had a newsletter I'm
gonna check it out I love buffer happen
yeah cool I mean mines I guess to the
point of the subject line my instinct
was subject is more important and I'm
just curious now thinking about it if
you posted a newsletter with no subject
what would happen if it would get open
if you get the response rate you know
like if you had if you tried to drive
people to a website and you had it you
had an amazing subject line and just the
link to the website right where it says
no subject line amazing copy and the
link to the website what would get more
action I'd be good test I mean at the
end of the day test right the answer
that everything in marketing this test
test test and see what works but I think
my gut says subject is more important
but you know I could be proven wrong
through the test yeah
NFC business cards we receive and see a
lot of emails how can we trust them if
I'm a marketing services if I'm
marketing services or products how can
you trust emails I guess is that
question there they're saying that in
terms of what they receive themselves or
is someone sending something how do they
ensure trust whatever it takes you want
to put on it there's no extra context
beyond that I mean so let's take it from
the angle of like you know if you're a
business how do you ensure trust in that
as a business you're trying to get into
the inbox you know expectation setting
is probably number one so that someone's
more inclined to receive or get your
inbox or your
and open your email because let's
remember the you know success is not
just getting in the inbox the success is
getting the recipient to do something
with that email in your inbox so setting
expectations when you're capturing the
name it's gonna come weekly and you're
gonna get this or if they download a PDF
it's it's setting the tone that says if
you want to sign up for more emails or
other emails again giving them the
option but setting the expectations
that's that's a primary way to build
trust I guess on the other side if
you're the recipient and you're
wondering like who's this brand and
where this brand come from well if
that's your immediate reaction then I
would say your immediate action to that
reaction is going to be to unsubscribe
because it is something that clearly is
not meeting your expectation or it's
something somehow your name got into a
list or someone's audience that you're
not really expecting you know so and we
all open up emails every day where we
say like where's this coming from
it may take some time to like you know
get you to remember like oh yeah I
remember I sign up for that here and
there but if your initial reaction as an
end user is I don't know where this came
from then unsubscribe is your first step
yeah I agree I think other things to add
trust 1oa chill your face show your
picture on there show your signature
have a personal message tell me why this
is so important to you I think that's
your advantage as an entrepreneur that's
how you beat the big guys is telling
your personal story and letting your
passion shine through I think too if you
have any kind of sizable list I know at
least Aweber has a little Chiclets that
you can put up that shows how many
people are on your list so if they know
that they're joining a list of already
you know a thousand people or more it's
not like oh I have three people on this
newsletter list oh I don't know I don't
know Eric if you have any kind of
guidance on that like when you start
publishing your numbers on your email
list but I think that helps add some
credibility and trust too so it's not
just you know one person on your list
yeah I mean even even and that's another
conversation that always comes up is
just oh I only have 50 names or only
have five people
if you
if you have those people you know at
your office or in your living room that
that's you know that's a pretty Hardy
conversation to have no matter what the
number is so you know if you're gonna
use that it's kind of like the the
social proof and the fear of missing out
in terms of using that with your sign up
form like join you know 500 other you
know experts in your field by signing up
now you know I'd say depending on your
niche if you're in a crowded marketplace
you probably need you know a couple
hundred couple thousand but like they
you know he said it before is uh tested
out because even by having you know that
few hundred scarcity equals values so if
there's only five hundred people and I
want to be five hundred and one well
then I'm probably gonna you know think
about joining well there's there's a lot
of excitement about the conversation
having about embedding forms into a
YouTube video if there's a technical way
to make that happen
I will I will guinea pig that for you no
problem Sherry's asking is it wise to
buy email lists I had a sense that this
question would be coming and again going
back to that roundtable as part of you
know that was a very hot topic because
for the b2b space and this is a
conversation have a one person about
they're very actively purchasing lists
and when I you know I just out of my
curiosity I asked more questions about
where are they coming from how do you
get them and as she explained the value
of doing that and that you know buying
fifty thousand names at a clip you know
with certain parameters was working in
their mind when I asked more about like
okay so where are those names coming
from and how are you sure and just kind
of like digging deeper you know my
answer is always gonna be the same it's
it's something that I would not
recommend doing because you know the her
question was okay well then what else
how else do I you know grow list at
scale and when we started talking about
that content piece and the expectation
setting you know it was an avenue that
had not been pursued so again whatever
your industry of your product or service
there's probably some information that
you have that someone else would find
valuable that would help you grow and
maintain that list so I mean you know
short answer I don't agree with buying
lists
and I'm happy to list anybody who's
doing it and having success because
quite frankly that would be a great
education moment for myself to
understand how they go about doing it
but from from a hey you know from a
quick start to grow your list would
certainly recommend against it yeah I
mean I agree I think this question was
asked when John was on - yeah um and he
have the same answer yeah you know you
don't want to be in the business of
spamming people unsolicited emails is
not how you want to get out there you
want to build the relationship and I
think that the people it's tempting
because you want to do it fast right
like hey I want to get to a thousand
names ten thousand names fifty thousand
names and when somebody says hey I can
get you in front of a million people
it's tempting you know for only fifty
bucks right but if the deal is that good
you really gotta consider the quality of
that list right and I think your best
bet to kind of ramp it up again is to if
you're going to do some kind of email
partnership they have it as a
recommendation so if you're you know if
you connect with if you can do something
like me I have 75,000 people on my list
and I work hard to build up if I endorse
you or say hey come check out this
product that I'm using or this video
that I'm doing together that's the
fastest way I think to be able to build
your list you can piggyback off of other
people but get a genuine endorsement
from people who actually care about
their lists I think I'll get a lot more
success than just buying names a great
great cool where I mean it's it's an
hour it's insane how fast it goes for
those of you who still have questions
Boris the pit
Dennis new future build a resale world
Nathan thank you guys so much for tuning
in for watching
Erik for people who want to learn more
about you and a weber and what's going
on what's the best place to go
any questions any weber you can feel
free to email me directly
pretty easy it's in the link below - you
guys can check it out
or yeah or as i say connect on twitter
at eric Hardison perfect great I'll
include that actually in the description
as well
yeah Oh Eric thank you so much to
spending time with us really appreciate
it thank you guys all for watching and
we'll see you on a hangout soon Ben
awesome thanks Evan thanks everyone